hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning today i'm
going to talk about noticing our
mistakes
and remember if you like these videos
please subscribe i talk about language
learning mostly
um i'm back from my
extended trip i was in slovakia i was in
vienna but mostly i was in ukraine and
mostly i was in la vie and i had a
fabulous time and i still remember
fondly the city all the different
squares the streets
it was spectacular i really recommend
that people visit levi
now on my
previous video i said that i was a
little i wouldn't say put off but i was
having my uh last lesson in la viv with
solomia and again i got the wrong case
endings and so she corrected me which is
good really
and then we kind of walked through
the case endings of different different
nouns
and it kind of put me off because i was
trying to get up some momentum
in my ukrainian and of course having
spent all that time i felt that i had
improved and then of course she reminded
me that i still make mistakes on some of
my case endings
and so i said you know when she did that
she kind of upset my timing a bit and if
i were just allowed to speak then i
would uh it would gradually get better
which is probably true
but
i want to change i want to go back on
what i said
i think it is true that that going
through all the case endings whether
you're doing it orally or whether you're
reading tables of case endings
is is not a very productive thing to do
although you know you need to
occasionally glance at them but i've
done it so often and been so
disappointed that my ability to retain
anything from that exercise
however
what solomia did was to make me aware of
the fact that
as much as i'm speaking ukrainian and
enjoying it and understanding it
i'm still making mistakes in my cases so
i said you know i got to do something
about that
and what am i gonna do so i went to link
and i went
every time there was a noun or an
adjective i saved a phrase
i saved a phrase and then i tagged it
i tagged it
you know according to the case that it
was either instrumental case
or you know accusative or genitive
maybe i got the odd one wrong but i
could go and look it up
so i got into the habit there of tagging
every single but every single noun every
single adjective but not as an
individual word but as a phrase
that way when i come across these
phrases again i see them plus i can go
to my vocabulary section and call up you
know locative case or instrumental case
and see all the examples
that i've saved and so i'm getting again
this concentrated
exposure to phrases where
one or and sometimes in some cases two
cases appear in the same phrase
i
it became it made me more aware
and i think that's what's so important
is to start to notice and to be aware
i should say first of all solomia's
corrections made me aware that i'm still
not as good as i'd like to be with my
case endings made me determined to do
something about it so now i'm i'm
tagging all of these and reviewing them
and what's more on the flight home i was
reading a book in ukrainian
that solomia had had given me a very
interesting book and there in pencil i
was marking up the book g for genitive l
for locative i for instrumental every
single
noun and adjective
i was noticing forcing myself to notice
what that case was
i have the feeling that those things if
i keep doing it are going to
help me
notice better be more aware
of these
endings and how they how they act in
phrases i think trying to save
individual words and tagging them is
less effective than saving the phrases
and of course that link in our
vocabulary review area you can review
just phrases uh you can also review you
know by whatever tag you have
i think this would be interesting to do
in other languages as well so in my
greek now i've gone back to greek
so i'm also trying to
tag the phrases for
genitive or accusative which in some
cases in greek is the same ending
and i think this can be done
for you know verbs in the romance
languages which cause so much trouble
uh if uh you can tag for you know first
purge you can tag it for person
and you can tag it
for tense
so that you can review for example just
the imperfect tense or just the simple
past
or a certain person and a certain tense
and review them in phrases now since i'm
not working on a romance language right
now
it's not something i'm going to do i'm
going to stick with ukrainian in greek
but if some of you want to try that i'd
be interested in hearing and again an
extension of this noticing and tagging
at link is to if you have a book that
you don't mind marking up to do the same
thing when you're reading in a book so
you're constantly forcing yourself to
notice these things
as you're reading now i must admit on
the plane i i did i would do this for a
while in my book that i was reading
and then i would not do it for a while
so that i'd kind of get more momentum
into reading the book and then i'd go
back to do it doing it and i i it's not
a matter of one or two days i think this
is something one has to keep on doing
for at least a couple of weeks but it
increases our our sensitivity our
awareness our ability to notice these
things which i expect especially we do
it with phrases will translate into an
ability to produce
these features of the language
more naturally so i just thought i'd
comment on that so again thanks to
solomia who by the way is a tremendous
teacher and i didn't want to be critical
of her and she certainly triggered
a consciousness
on my part
that i want to work harder to nail my
cases
and once i've done this with cases i may
go and do this the same with different
verbs of motion or perfective and
imperfect verbs those things that cause
me the most trouble in slavic languages
and i can do it in in czech and in
polish and in russian as well
so there you have it on noticing sort of
a sequel to the issue of of corrections
and again if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
and i look forward to your comments and
i would be particularly interested if
some of you try to do this on link or at
least even marking up books and if you
feel that it
helps you
you know deal with those issues in
another language that are
often the most difficult because they're
different to what we have in our in in
the languages that we already speak
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you